[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis en train de
préparer le matos pour la vidéo de
demain une grande vidéo parce qu'il y
aura demain une grande annonce et je
compte sur vous pour être présent pour
l'instant suis préparé car je n'ai pas
pondre ça va je suis en place bonjour
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous je suis
très content de me retrouver aujourd'hui
parce qu'on va parler du surplace phone
le futur probable smartphone pas
vraiment smartphones de microsoft est
justement et des choses super
intéressantes à dire dessus et on va en
parler
[Musique]
microsoft s'est planté ya quelques temps
avec l'univers du smartphone microsoft
est très fort sur les os sur les
ordinateurs portables et de bureau
il ya plein de domaines dans lequel
microsoft excel les consoles enfin voilà
ça vous connaissait donc je vais pas
vous refaire le le topo là dessus par
contre un domaine sur lequel sont pas
très bons mais sur lequel il risque de
révolutionner demain le marché c'est la
téléphonie mobile c'est le smartphone
lorsqu'ils ont réellement compris que
les produits tels qu'ils étaient
actuellement tels qu'ils sont présentés
n'ont que peu d'avenir
et justement ils vont dessiner l'avenir
de la téléphonie mobile et on va
regarder ça ensemble
avant toute chose avant d'aller plus
loin dans la vidéo je vous pose une
question est ce que vous vous avez une
idée de ce que va être le surface phone
avant d'aller plus loin avant de
regarder davantage la vidéo imiter la
pause et mettez moi en commentaire si
vous connaissez surface phone si vous
savez ce que ça va être
et si vous avez une petite idée
là-dessus je suis vraiment curieux de
faire ce sont là pour me rendre compte
un peu des informations que vous avez
des connaissances que vous avez des
choses que vous avez regardé avant donc
bloquer tout trichez pas cliché pas vous
mettez la pause sur la vidéo et
j'attends allez-y bon normalement là
vous avez mis la pause vos mets tes
lectures l'année votre commentaire donc
on peut y aller bon alors le surface
phone je vous explique un petit peu
microsoft effectivement comme je le dis
c'est planté au niveau des téléphones
mobiles mais c'est un segment ça a
marché sur lequel ils doivent absolument
être présent il leur faut une offre je
dirais à 360° au niveau l'high-tech que
ce soit les ordinateurs de bureau les
portables les os les consoles et tous
les appareils tous les appareils de
l'univers high-tech qui nous entoure il
faut que microsoft soit présent et il
faut tous ces appareils puissent
communiquer entre eux pour avoir un
écosystème global
c'est un peu ce que fait aujourd'hui
apple avec tous ces os mac os communique
avec ios tout est censé communiquer
ensemble ce soit la watch os ce soit à
la télé enfin voilà tout ce système là
communiquent ensemble pour avoir un
ensemble cohérent ce n'était qu'une fois
que vous avez mis un pied dans une
marque
en gros vous êtes serré vous est
verrouillé et vous restez et vous
acheter l'ensemble et c'est exactement
que cette stratégie que doit adopter
microsoft pour qu'on puisse retrouver
une offre quand
microsoft mais pour réussir
effectivement ce pari ils doivent être
présent sur tous les segments donc
justement ce surface phone devrait être
un peu l'élément manquant de microsoft
et devrait vraiment révolutionné la
téléphonie mobile alors je vais vous
expliquer en quoi ça va révolutionner
une fois n'est pas coutume votre cher
monsieur greu a fait son travail avec
son écriture de démâter on sait que
c'est très très mal la fed a refait des
cahiers d'écriture et en gagnant mais
bon faut croire que ça n'a servi à rien
désolé ce surface phone devrait être un
produit complètement nouveau
un smartphone réinventer loin de tout ce
qu'on connaît actuellement
donc l'idée si vous voulez c'est de
faire un reset de notre connaissance au
terme de smartphones et de téléphonie
mobile alors on va commencer tout de
suite je vais vous parler de alex kipman
qui est l'inventeur du all all ends chez
microsoft et qui est un peu comment
dirais-je l'un des visionnaires de
microsoft donc c'est un petit peu si
vous voulez l'homme du futur dans le
présent de microsoft selon l'ex kipman
le téléphone est déjà mort mais les gens
ne l'ont pas encore réalisé donc on ne
se rend pas compte tenu que les
smartphones qu'on utilise sont en
réalité des produits du passé le concept
des smartphones tels qu'on les connaît
actuellement serait donc voué à
disparaître et est remplacé par tout
autre chose
c'est vraiment intéressant et
passionnant parce que je pense que c'est
assez vrai c'est assez juste
on est arrivé au bout de quelque chose
on est arrivé au bout de ce qu'on peut
avoir et attendre de ces produits là
alors effectivement on peut voir
toujours plus de belles photos on peut
voir des choses encore plus puissante
on peut améliorer je dire un peu les
concepts présents pour en tirer le
meilleur pour en tirer l'essence mais
au-delà de ça un moment va falloir
réinventer l'histoire pour offrir
quelque chose de vraiment nouveau et
c'est justement là dessus que planches
microsoft je suis sûr que si vous
regardez vos paramètres d'utilisation
d'ailleurs je vais faire ma tout de
suite dans votre téléphone vous utilisez
pas énormément votre téléphone en mode
téléphone au cours des dernières 24
heures j'ai utilisé
je sais pas si vous le voyez bien mais
email à 21% j'ai utilisé
youtube studio à 9% et mon téléphone à
lui pour cent le constat est arrivé
aujourd'hui que votre téléphone n'est
plus utilisé en fonction principale
comme un téléphone donc on est plus sur
un téléphone
on est sur un assistant de vie
personnelle je sais pas si on peut
appeler ça comme ça
combien dans votre poche donc l'idée
c'est de le faire évoluer
ne pas forcément gardé ce format là mais
d'aller plus loin d'ailleurs j'ai eu une
réflexion par rapport à ça lorsque j'ai
acheté une tablette que j'ai acheté mon
premier ipad fort et c'est génial c'est
d'avoir un plus grand écran petite table
et que par des vols soit dans son pieu
emmené quand on voyage comme ça mais la
tablette en réalité fait vraiment
doublon avec ça vous retrouvez
d'ailleurs la plupart nos applications
là dessus sont les mêmes développé pour
plus grand écran sont des applications
pour smartphones pour trôner sur
tablette donc l'idée c'est de réunir
tout ça dans un seul et même produit 100
kg et doublons d'où l'idée de microsoft
d'aller plus loin sur leur smartphone
et ça c'est vraiment intéressant ce que
proposerait microsoft ça serait un peu
l'idée de ça je prends mon cahier à
spirales dans lequel je travaille merci
week au passage de m'avoir donné
j'utilise énormément l'idée c'est ça
alors je le format est pas du tout bon
vous auriez donc un téléphone avec ce
format là lorsque vous l'ouvrirez
lorsque lorsque vous devriez l'ouvrir et
bien vous auriez un grand écran qui
viendraient s'ouvrir ici vous pourriez
leur à battre pour avoir un écran de ce
côté là un écran de ce côté là on
pourrait l'imaginer l'utiliser comme ça
avec un os qui serait complètement
adaptatif donc vous auriez plusieurs
écrans votre grand écran au centre un
seul même et grand écran un écran en
façade et au dos probablement pas grand
chose votre smartphone se transformerait
en tablette
alors la question maintenant est ce que
ce sera un écran pliable ou alors deux
écrans ni bord à bord c'est un peu la
question du moment d'ailleurs je vous ai
fait une vidéo dessus sur les écrans
pliables que je vous invite à aller voir
pour vous rencontrent un petit peu
l'utilité et voir c'est vraiment
vraiment très très passionnant parce que
c'est là dessus qu'on va aller à
l'avenir alors pour l'instant c'est pas
énormément il ya des croquis qui ont été
sortis et qui montreraient a priori ce
serait deux écrans distincts
ça serait un peu dommage parce que alors
qu'on va aller vers des écrans pliables
avoir deux écrans séparés
c'est un petit peu le produit tiède
après une fois de plus rien d'officiel
du côté microsoft
donc on peut très bien imaginer qu'il ya
eu des premiers croquis qui vont être
réajusté en fonction des techno
si les écrans pliables sont complètement
maîtrisé par microsoft
ils peuvent aller plus loin et ça peut
être intéressant donc voila un petit peu
l'idée du produit le concept tel qu'il
est fait en os on devra trouver un
windows disent complètement adapté aux à
la téléphonie mobile et à ce système là
il s'appellerait le windows core os
comme je dis ça sera un windows 10
amélioré qui pourra du moins communiquer
avec votre ordinateur portable avec
votre tablette microsoft avec votre
ordinateur bureau avec tout un
écosystème cohérent ni crosoft alors il
ya une rumeur qui est intéressante aussi
toujours à prendre avec des pincettes
alex kipman c'est l'inventeur de
lawrence et donc ça nous amène à cette
rumeur qui dirait que on pourrait
retrouver une projection holographique
des hologrammes
si vous voulez sur ce smartphone ça
pourrait aussi être une idée du futur
parce que et qu'elle se sent qu'elle il
faut être très clair c'est que
aujourd'hui les produits tels qu'on les
a aujourd'hui en 2018 tous les appareils
du dur c'est d'y smartphone c'est du
concret mais on va aller davantage vers
des produits dématérialisés
on aura toujours une surface hardware
parce que de toute façon il faut bien
avoir des puces il faut bien voir que
quelque chose de physique de présent
mais on pourrait très bien imaginer par
exemple que votre watch votre montre
connectés soit plus qu'il monte
collectés mais deviennent vraiment le
centre névralgique
aujourd'hui le centre névralgique de
votre vie numérique c'est ça demain ça
pourrait être ça imaginez que les écrans
soit plus grands pourquoi pas des écrans
pliables des meilleures surfaces et une
montre optimisé il ya un vrai sens à au
fait de se dire que vous avez vos emails
ici quelque chose qui peut-être s'ouvrir
je sais pas après comment ça pourrait
être fait vous pourrez téléphoner avec
vos airpod vous pourriez avoir
différentes applications et vous passez
de cette grosse bête que vous aurez dans
votre poche c'est vraiment de
dématérialiser les produits high tech
pour aller plus loin de ce qu'on sait
microsoft pourrait travailler avec
qualcomm est équipé son surface phone
d'un processeur snapdragon
alors pour l'instant effectivement je
n'ai pas vous parler de chiffres deux
processeurs de ram de capacité de
stockage parce que là vraiment ça serait
parler parler dans le vent là on parle
vraiment du conseil sur lequel travaille
microsoft pour faire un grand come back
avec un produit complètement réinventé
il me remettre un grand coup de pied
dans la fourmilière dans le marché
j'ai des smartphones dans le marché de
la téléphonie mobile il est complètement
impossible de dire si ce surface fun va
sortir si on le verra un jour peut-être
pas sous ce nom peut-être un autre nom
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y aura
un produit qui va venir bousculer un peu
les tendances et qui va venir changer la
donne alors est-ce qu'il viendra de
microsoft en premier ou des autres
concurrents ça c'est pareil on reste un
petit peu dans le flou artistique
surface phone pourrait voir le jour
on croise les doigts pour qu'il arrive
en 2018 et ce qui est sûr est ce qu'on
sent vraiment s'il voulait au travers de
ceux de ce genre produits et au travers
de ce genre d'annoncés sont les
tendances
parce que l'idée de toutes ces rumeurs
c'est pas de faire des vidéos de rumeurs
pour faire des vidéos de rumeurs mais
cette vidéo de rumeurs elles ont un vrai
intérêt c'est de sentir les tendances et
devoir dire quoi on se dirige
et qu'est ce que va être la technologie
demain adapté à nous et quelle manière
ça va nous influencer nous parce que ces
produits là ils ont très clairement
influencé notre changement notre
relation aux autres
donc les smartphones ce sont plus que
des outils high-tech qu'on utilise en
plus que des outils ce sont vraiment des
objets qui quelque part même si c'est
regrettable façonnent notre façon de
vivre et façonnent notre relation aux
autres
donc voila c'était une vidéo avec un peu
plus conceptuel un peu plus
philosophique autour tout ça mais c'est
vraiment intéressant
et justement c'est ce genre de chose qui
est vraiment passionnante
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous pensez vous
réellement que se surpasse phone peut
changer la donne peut changer nos vies
numériques
mettez moi tout ça je vous invite bien
évidemment comme d'habitude admirer des
jolies pousse américaine parce que moi
je vous like je vous invite bien sûr à
vous abonner parce qu'on va encore plus
parler de high tech parler des tendances
parler des produits sentir ce qui est
arrivé c'est comprendre ces produits
technologiques et en quoi ils changent
nos vies et en quoi ils influencent nos
vies bien qu'on s'en rendent pas
toujours compte donc abonnez vous restez
connectés n'oubliez pas vous êtes les
meilleurs n'oublie pas que je vous l
attention à vous prenez soin de vous et
surtout restez connectés parce que dès
demain on va parler de plein de choses
dingues justement pour en parler
je vais commencer à m'habiller parce que
je vous dis un seul truc c'est que
demain ça va cahier alors ça va cahier à
sa racaille est grave ça c'est sûr je
vais le peler les miches
parce que dès demain on part en voyage
et comme je suis à m hypra coule et que
bien évidemment je vous kiffe
je vous emmène avec moi
la poche on part ensemble on va aller
voir les chose de dingue on va se peler
les miches pendant quelques jours on va
partir à -11 degrés voire moins 15
degrés et après on va partir à plus 20
degrés donc restez connectés je vous
aide et je vous dis à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]